now let's try finding the square root of
11,000 25 using the prime factorization
method hence our aim would be to reduce
11,000 25 into its prime factors so we
write 11,000 25 here and draw 2 lines
like this if we know the rules of
divisibility well we can say that this
number is divisible by 3 5 and 7 so we
can start with any prime number say 5 so
5 x 2,205 gives us 11,000 25 this number
again is divisible by 5
hence we write a 5 here and 5 multiplied
by 441 gives us 2,205 of course you
would take a bit more time to find the
numbers here but that's perfectly
alright and remember we keep just the
prime factors on the left hand side now
since 441 is divisible by 3 let us write
3 here and 3 x 147 gives us 441 this
number is also divisible by 3 and 3 x 49
equals 147 and the only prime number 49
is divisible by is 7 and 7 multiplied by
7 is 49 and yes we stopped here since 7
is a prime number so 11,000 25 can be
written as 5 times 5 times 3 times 3
times 7 times 7
hence the square root of 11,000 25 can
be written as square root of 5 times 5
times 3 times 3 times 7 times 7 the next
step is to make pairs of the same
numbers and after we find the pair's
we choose one number from each pair so
we have three pairs here a pair of 5s a
pair of threes and a pair of 7s we
choose one number from each pair so from
the first pair
we choose five from the second pair we
choose three and from the third pair we
choose a seven and to find the square
root all we have to do is multiply these
numbers 5 x 3 x 7 equals 105 hence the
square root of 11,000 25 is 105 this
part of the problem where we choose one
number from each pair is really simple
what we really need to be good at is
finding out the prime factors quickly
here's another interesting thing you
need to know finding the prime factors
of large numbers can be difficult and
tedious so yes there is a better way to
find them which we will see in the
coming videos
you